holiday reeks it in driving shoveling
layup good pretty pass and the foul can
score but can they give back and stop
people you know this is a transition to
a schizo alter that was because Jackson
did a good job of challenging
steel breakout Stevenson he's going to
give it up off the phone Showtime
Lansing's Oh sparkling on that one
throws off the glass and so just hammers
it trying to go into the - - Lance I
think we tapped into it can the Pels
steal it from Brooklyn he's coming off
the pick holiday the mid-range game I
mean he wasn't even close and then drew
all pick and roll attacking the big pull
bottom
[Music]
fall off the screen this blinds are
bringin that slope
what Luke lawn and the lake is wanting
to do turns the corner and attacks
[Applause]
pretty play by Drew holiday you had 22
season 5 last night in Oakland gotta
watch them they drive to the basket more
than any teams of the lead Cody you
don't want to be on that poster at 21
and threw it away and Clarke after it
and points off the turnover it'll be
hard way blocked away
diello turns his back completely why was
town Lakers the fort's back into believe
[Applause]
he saved the turnover for yourself
didn't he
we're showing it now we're Lanza created
a sensation behind the back pass dodge
it's trying to get there where they get
that look back at this block right here
that's pretty amazing
I mean you can see him sizing that up
with a head of steam here's Galloway
he's pinned their best offensive player
in the second half look at that pass
down court about llamas old ball from
one end to the other a touchdown
it's not ad out there 77 66 Frazier our
check that drew nice nice move
protecting it on the reverse this is
just a pretty pretty finish
oh we gotta put it in reverse the
pelicans are down to two thirty left to
go in the third
use the coach there's a lot from teams
to fall that's a tough break
kept alive oh good job check the auto
settle the shot clock through to the
hole right at the shop walk right tape
Myles Turner out of the equation
completely that's outstanding all day
with nine of the last 18 elegant points
to get right where they need to be just
now three and a nice finish
it's made a conscious effort not to talk
about how difficult the road could be
there go for take a pass family you can
get this you know that with the left
hand
how about that Eddie gets the roll six
point game
that's juicy that's three thousand
look at that sauce LeBron been on the
clock of it three minutes in OT lonzo's
gonna try it three feet back down
[Music]
I like him he doesn't hesitate cuddly
and that's what course the miss by
DeRozan ronzo though the kit and now of
the second app as well sure on the run
with AD as a decoy going to the look at
the three-point play counted he was hit
on his way
he sees that'll open up and just eyes
light up let me go get this
[Music]
LeBron ride while loves it in Lanza
laughs good position for the mismatch
against Peyton LeBron he sought Lonzo
did two and one distortive passed even
good-looking good use of the height
advantage by marzo against a three-point
opportunity Stillwater together now the
shot flags all the way down drew with
Danny Green it's going up triple for
Drew yes
that's huge 15-point lead biggest to the
game but it comes with five minutes the
blood SIOC up in the corner here at
Joe's going to be off want soap collects
it outlet got it here he goes one two
he wanted to back down drew holiday
[Applause]
maybe that'll pick it up at the
offensive end of the floor when your
guard brings in like that Wesley Johnson
finishes that when he took and
there's the block and the break the
other way buddy it's out of the shot for
the Lakers in double figures right back
to steai from Phelps good read by law
explosives steal the store for Lonzo
ball boots as the lead steel over 2022
to be exact
holiday Meritage got what he wanted man
out of position top the shine vine for
true little step through he's going to
the line looking at the three-point
place marked he didn't settle at all did
he
[Music]
[Applause]
raps a little further away that in what
a tune he still threw it down right
scientists worked Anthony right under
the basket he got what he wanted
Holliday underneath flips it up and in
from the reverse side
here's Holliday is what we're talking
about as far as his aggressiveness McGee
event picking up his ball again pushing
the face drives and lays it in mark you
said it earlier a different player cost
of the game this is who he's he's got a
peak he's got to be this guy he gave up
the trouble main tell me how they
thought about it against a real good
debater he'll take was a clever defender
nearly pucks it away he does
caldwell-pope finds James for the easy
dunk position to have the lead all of a
sudden intended them on the offensive
end give the Lakers credit elevated
their defense high percentage offense
off Turtles big-time finish by James
mr. holiday setting it up on Mac got
where he wanted to go right at the
buzzer
Shelvin Mack and drew sized it up
perfectly because he's got a big
advantage size-wise when Drew is on the
attack
playing downhill going right into the
middle of the defense and not get it
down
pelicans just down one after one stutter
step with the dribble have runs into the
double-team Collison stopped a fast
break a great angle but he makes a great
play on it as he gets to swat off the
glass and then pick it up he goes right
by middle Chico Alvin wanted to file
their game at the break but did he yes
yes just in time
[Music]
exceptional taste through knew exactly
what was left on the flag and the crew
started for Kippur they're just one for
six the before since that's what that is
bad Lonzo counted fowl nice blade set up
out of the timeout
good view cooking pans new city foul
holiday against dominating they're gonna
be a pic yes
multiple drew step ahead three eight
tenths of a second ago their franchise
leaders rebounds whose Donna's hands on
who'sa still with the team up to 16
years ones Oh take that three pecan you
got it you've got to make those you know
you get those opportunities and this
should be easy to with the left hand he
deserved it after the takeaway again and
he took it away from Lou Williams former
teammate of his with the 76ers
[Applause]
the Anthony Davis saga will certainly
continue oh nice little step through
there by holiday and Drew holiday scores
two more for the pelicans 59 year old
head coach and that right there just a
nice change of pace the long rebound and
Washington's on the lawn and of course
it's John Lonzo ball rejects John LA
County speed without getting contact
with the body and not picking up the
foul the contact that was with the body
but it wasn't the right arm again up
against Brown by Brown of the shoulder
works
that'll do it who asked the last points
to the Lakers if I try it again
do
so ball control over doesn't get another
looking Lonzo knocking down the shot at
they give it to him he's feeling it from
long distance right now not rushing out
at all on him yeah that monster block
late and at the end of the quarter true
holiday fills it up brave recognition
first triple of the game for the PALS
Falls at the end of the first quarter
locker room
Lonzo
[Applause]
great defensive play budgeting holiday
there's a good rebounder as well comes
away with the board ball pushes goes
right to the rim
burst of speed and a chance for a
three-point play they get downhill they
put the black basketball in his hands I
think this time we plays a little too
unselfish he's got to look to be a
scorer taking it to the body the contact
and going to the line he's John he is on
Team LeBron isn't he he is well you can
tell by the boos ball George back in the
game Paul and another block this time on
Westbrook tank as you go to the cup
there's a little contact with good job
defensively by Alonzo walk and we look
at the score business deep come on drew
he knew it all the time did me
[Applause]
so that's the way they'll have to attack
the Renault with 737 Lonzo gets to the
rim for the flush and that was followed
up by Brandon Ingram so he's picking up
where he left off as a member the
Clippers could take drew how it goes to
the stripe looking for the three-point
play
a little more I can get this done I can
bring us back so balls sirs max our
largest clue to the game and take it
away Simmons coming up drew didn't quit
on the play
check it away from behind on the take
julius randle going to the line look
into the three-point play
drew gets back into play nicely head up
I always wondered what guys did put the
ball of energy throughout Lakers down -
with the basketball
what's all up the alley oop the possible
dirt was dare he tried to jump get a
look at that pass and Josh art to punt
so and he just came at me that's what
I'm watching is Williams doing drew deep
that was real deep he interrupted boys
from Scottsdale walked to the scorer's
table have the starters back into the
game sewing this is good tap out by
style Kuzma Lonzo dishes to bar soft
touch
they've changed drew inside and chat
setup served up on a plate Raja listen
speed downhill he goes me was surrounded
by a trio of all the doors speed is what
got that basket into a speed of lawns
open right down the middle for the deuce
nice play it's a dove eight to play in
the half drew Holloway got the triple
that time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hope how about the assist this is why
everybody loves ship execution was was
always good was something watch drill
holiday
England's can't do much about that can't
stand to watch take a look in coach but
he thought the biggest dip is for Paul
George word this year and he said
understanding has ball knocks down the
dunk with understanding the fast pace
that Westbrook plays with Alfred Payton
out there with Drew holiday feast angles
on the up leaps it off ad drew got the
die because he brought bear to the
[Applause]
Rockies sister of his contract I've
never taken fifth overall you remember
you know dime good bounce entry Drew's
got the easy one good lead the buy ad
bells by three lines Oh ball nice little
fake and banker that is so hard to guard
when you drive it hard stop and give it
away what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content